now i hate to say i told you so but i've
just said it and while i always knew
there was much potential for using crisp
activation for cellular reprogramming
and now we have a paper that suggests in
more detail how and that it's very
effective
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we'll
take a look at this paper crisp
activation enables high fidelity
reprogramming into human pluripotent
stem cells and a deep dive into crispr
crispr activation and also cellular
reprogramming
so firstly before we go any further we
just need me to explain what cellular
reprogramming actually is
and well let's go back to 2006 when
shinya yamanaka published the now
landmark study whereby the introduction
of four factors the yamanaka factors
oskm which when expressed in
differentiated mouse cells could reverse
them to pluripotent stem cells
these are cells that have the potential
to divide continuously but also to
differentiate into different cell types
so they were termed induced peripotent
stem cells
and so this is where the reprogramming
comes in because you effectively alter
you reprogram a cell's identity
now i've made a few recent videos on
cellular reprogramming but i think it's
important to reiterate why there is much
interest around it and there are three
main reasons
firstly for disease modeling for example
if you wanted to study neurons of an
individual
instead of taking their actual neurons
which would be quite challenging to do
you could instead derive them from a
stem cell
and get that stem cell from one of their
skin cells using this reprogramming
technology
secondly you can use it to understand
the biology of cell states
and also cellular plasticity how easy
and difficult it is for cells
to be reprogrammed
by chemistry nerdiness
and then lastly for rejuvenative
regenerative medicine approaches
so the common method of reprogramming is
giving cells the genes encoding their
reprogramming factors such that they are
overexpressed
however
having this forced expression of ectopic
genes can cause the following problems
of target gene activation
so you're expressing genes that you
don't really want to be expressed which
potentially could be due to having a
high concentration of these
reprogramming factors
that may bind to dna or they wouldn't
otherwise
secondly it can result in heterogeneous
reprogramming and that can result in two
different outcomes besides having a stem
cell
as the best case scenario when you're
doing reprogramming is to well achieve
free programming but you may also cause
a cell to die it may cause the cell to
become senescence or it may become
transformed and cancerous
not so good
but why does this happen and is there
any way to make this more controlled and
safe
and so on from this the cells that do
become stem cells may be aberrant
so what is normal cellular reprogramming
and how does crispr help
well once these yamanaka factors are
expressed the assumption is that they
will then activate other genes and the
downstream consequence of these events
results in a cell changing its
epigenetic landscape and stabilizing
into the stem cell states
so what would be desirable features for
reprogramming technology
well i would like a reprogramming
technology that matches my personality
reliable
efficient
safe with a good sense of humor
okay we couldn't scratch the good sense
of humor
but anyway
reliable we want to know it's going to
reprogram and not do something weird e.g
not die or become senescent
and also we don't want the cell to try
get halfway and go
that [ __ ] i'm not going
you want it to fully commit
and i suppose tied into this as you want
it to be reproducible you want it to do
the same thing every time
and then efficiency reprogramming can
take time the cells need to make some
serious changes you might think slow and
steady is potentially the best approach
you know you can't rush great art but
maybe a longer duration also means the
sale was more likely to go off track so
maybe shorter is better
and then safe which uh given my recent
by accident this probably isn't a
personality trait of mine though i do
sometimes wear my lab coats
anyway safety goes back to what i was
saying with reliability we don't want
the cell to become uncontrolled and
cancerous we want to know that it's
trustworthy
so crisp activation
now almost a year ago i told you about
crisp activation even though it's been
around for much longer than that but
essentially it's a modified version of
crispr so conventional crispr you have a
guide rna that recognizes a specific
site on dna
and then you have a protein that binds
that guide
cas9 class 9 this protein has the
activity to cut dna and make a double
stranded break
you can then change the sequence of the
guide rna and target the crispr complex
elsewhere
in crispr activation
we mutate cas9 so that it doesn't cop
dna but it retains that site-specific
binding activity
and also you can tag cas9 with other
small proteins that promote
transcription so expression of genes
and so what would happen is you target
cas9 upstream of a gene you want to
express so let's say the yamanaka
factors and it can activate gene
expression
so that's why it's called crisp
activation
um so the key difference is that this is
so called endogenous expression not
ectopic
and it's actually been done already
before using the four yamanaka factors
so oct4 sox2 klf4 and mick plus lin 28a
and the motif express no genes expressed
in early development that they call eea
but the thing was this crisp activation
approach had pretty low reprogramming
efficiency so not really fulfilling my
personality checklist
so this brings me on to the new
publication where they conclude that
these findings support the use of crispr
a for high quality pluripotent
reprogramming of human cells
so how did they do it and are there
advantages or disadvantages to the
crispr approach over these more
conventional ectopic gene expression
approaches
so to speed up their discovery process
of other potential target sites they use
the system that enables reprogrammed
cells to be easily detected and analyzed
so their approach involves using cells
that grow in suspension but then attach
to the surface of a plate when
reprogrammed
by doing that they identified the most
efficient reprogramming when they had
extra eea targeting and when they
targeted the promoter of mir-32367
this latter thing is still a gene but
instead of creating for a protein it
cares for a micro rna
i don't have the time to go into all the
details as to like how these are
expressed or why they work
but i did make a video a few years back
with more details if you want to learn
more
but like with the activation of the
yamanaka factors which are transcription
factors that can regulate the expression
of multiple other genes
micrornas can also influence many
different genes and so you get much bang
for your buck
but one of the rationales for these
specific micrornas is that they reduce
the expression of some factors that
repress reprogramming so you're
repressing the repressors
anyway with this extra eea targeting and
the micro rna targeting they called
their technique
crispr a plus me
it's getting very personal today but me
here stands for the micro rna sites
they're targeting and e for the eea
metis
anyway that was a cancer cell line but
they also showed that it worked in human
fibroblasts and crispr plus me was the
only reprogramming condition that
properly induced induced pluriplated
stem cell colonies
from fibroblasts derived from an 83 year
old man
and this is a cell line that's known to
be difficult to reprogram
and so the cool thing that they also did
in this paper
was that they did single cell rna
sequencing to see the gene expression
profiles of the cells using this
approach compared to a transgenic
approach
what they observed based on the gene
expression was that mid reprogramming so
around so day 15 the crispr a plus me
cells looked more like the reprogrammed
cells
than the other transgenic approaches
suggesting that the kinetics of
reprogramming were also being enhanced
so that's how but what are the
advantages of using this crisp a
well as i mentioned earlier you're
expressing the endogenous genes
and you're modifying the epigenetic
landscape in situ
and by having this endogenous instead of
exogenous expression you also retain
extra steps of gene expression such as
splicing and regulatory elements which
may also influence
the control over the expression of these
factors which might be useful from a
safety perspective
and then the second thing with using
crispr in general is that it enables
high multiplexing once you've got cast 9
you can just add multiple guide rnas for
different sites that you want to target
so this is the magical summary figure
you start with some differentiated cells
add the crispr machinery targeting
yamanaka plus more eea and microrna 302
and you get induced pluripotent stem
cells
i think there's many studies that could
be done to further explore this
technology i think it'd be kind of cool
to see
well
if they could better map out the
chromatin landscape of these cells and
also see potentially why the
transcription factors the yamanaka
factors are binding in these cells
compared to the other approaches
to further understand you know what is
about this approach that seems to be
more effective
um and then they can link it back to
their transcriptomic changes
but anyway i'm digressing so can crispr
solve aging well guess we'll have to
wait and see but whether it's through
crisp activation or other crispr
techniques i've not mentioned in this
video such as gene editing knockout
screens or
using alternative cast proteins for
diagnostics it will certainly aid in our
future understanding of the aging
process and how best to treat and
diagnose for it
so with that i'd like to thank myself
for making this video
and all the cells involved thank you to
my patreon supporters and thanks for
listening
you